so now first speaker of the session we
have the wafer yes from MIT we talk
about optimal a/b testing actual problem
so thanks very much for for inviting me
I'm very very glad to be here so I'm
going to talk about a/b testing and I'll
make the notion of what I mean precise
in just a bit
but I think we all kind of have a sense
of what what they be testing means and
the twenty thousand sort of foot view of
the talk is really to kind of view this
through the lens of sort of an
optimization framework okay and what
that will lead to is interesting
optimization problems both insert of the
offline setting as well as the online
setting okay and so the goal in some
ways is is more or less to introduce
those problems and then see a little bit
about the results we have for those
problems and you know time permits
there's sort of a long list of I think
effectively open problems that it that
this this sort of view leads to and I'd
like to spend some time on that as well
this is joint work with my French team
ACMA Lemmy who's at Columbia and nickel
bud who's at at Airbnb so so just got
started on here right so what's the
prototypical a be test so the
prototypical a/b test right is you've
got two treatments it's a or b and i'm
not gonna write here B I'm gonna call
them plus or minus one you have some
population of subjects right let's call
that set capital Omega you have some
measure of sort of the efficacy of
treatment right and that's this function
y right that's a function of little
Amega in omega and also where they use
plus one or minus one okay at the end of
the day really what you're trying to get
to is some formalization of is it better
to do plus one or is it better to do
minus 1 right and so there's a bunch of
different you know measures of that that
you can propose and let's say you have a
distribution for instance over a mega
you know you could propose to talk about
the average treatment effect a very
common measure right that says okay I
you know I want to figure out whether
you know using plus one is better than
using minus one average
on average a vice versa okay so that's
what we'd like to get to obviously now
this is not something we can necessarily
compute so it's the simplest thing we
could do you know the simplest thing we
can do is you know something that we've
been doing probably for I don't know 50
or 60 maybe of a hundred years
right which is a randomized trial so
what's a randomized trial in this
setting the simplest randomized trial
right is you just do the following right
subjects are sort of independently
assigned to either plus 1 or minus 1
right let's keep it really really simple
let's say I sort of equal probability
right subjects got assigned to either
plus 1 or minus 1 at the end of the day
you'll sort of come up with an empirical
estimate for this by just sort of
replacing each of these with empirical
averages okay so that's that's that sort
of a vanilla a sort of randomized trial
now I'm gonna sort of talk spend a lot
of time effectively talking about you
know why this isn't enough and what
optimizations problems this this
actually leads to yeah so magazine cap
Omega so a generic element of capital
omegas omegas
yeah so you know I'll get to sort of
what the what the real issues are right
why can't we just stop here but before
doing that I sort of wanted to give you
guys a sense that you know sort of a
broad spectrum of problems even outside
the healthcare setting that we saw for
instance in the first talk where this
kind of stuff is interesting so you know
the first talk was was all about these
sort of clinical trials you know just to
get a sense you know in a cancer trial I
think Don if he's around can probably
correct me here but in a cancer child
right the cost of an individual sample
is sort of twenty to forty thousand
dollars right so these are expensive
samples there's lots of challenges
beyond just sort of things like
statistical efficiency that were alluded
to in the in the in the first talk see
Mac and I kind of got into this not so
much from this angle but a couple of
different motivating motivating problems
so for one nikhil was working on this
problem at air B&B of quote/unquote
fixing bad hosts so i think we all know
what air B&B is some of us are probably
staying at an Airbnb right now right and
a bad host is basically as the name
suggests when you're host you know does
bad stuff right the place isn't ready or
whatever and so for Airbnb they're
constantly you know looking at ways to
intervene right to sort of make sure
that the hosts stop doing that bad stuff
now this is actually you know an
expensive time-consuming and tricky
thing to do and the way they've actually
set this up internally is effectively an
experimentation platform where you
actually try things be an a/b test so in
effect right if you want to figure out
what the best intervention is you run an
a/b test and so if you you know if you
make progress in some of this stuff you
can actually do this see mark and I have
been spending a good amount of time in
the last year with some folks in Amazon
where interestingly enough a beat us are
actually being used for inventory
management right which which seems sort
of bizarre but in a nutshell what it is
is the following the typical approach to
inventory management is you know has
been you know build a you build a nice
model you know some sort of dynamic
optimization problem you calibrate that
model to data you know come up with some
algorithms and you kind of go and do
that right in the kitchen Amazon the
problems are so complex and the dynamics
are so complex that you started out
with this approach of sort of building a
model of fitting at the data etc etc etc
you're kind of lost so instead they're
approaches they have a few parameters
think of it as five or six parameters
that they'd like to tweak and they
constantly want to be on the bleeding
edge of the right set of parameters okay
so the entire thing is sort of set up as
sort of a giant the giant a B test as a
giant a/b test and not just that right
this is this become so important yeah
that they're effectively companies
dedicated almost entirely to providing
infrastructure for these sorts of a B a
B test right so one big giant in that
space is apt that you know recently got
bought by I think MasterCard for a
billion dollars or something like that
you know Ramesh's I think giving the
talk tomorrow and the day after that
he's chief scientist at Optimizely and
tell you more about that I'm sure so
this has become sort of get a very very
important stuff so the question is again
right why can't we just stop at that
that randomized trial which seems pretty
simplistic and you know pack up and go
home the issue is the following the
thing that you're trying to measure
right the difference so to speak between
plus one and minus one is tiny okay at
the end of the day so think of this as
follows okay so you know let's say you
want to run an a/b test on what size
font is appropriate for an ad online
right
the impact of the font first I hope it
might not have an impact and if it does
have an impact it's likely to be tiny on
an already really small number okay so
the signal that you're trying to
estimate is actually fairly weak right
and then of course just sticking with
that example right if somebody
converting on an ad online you know and
that's not going to convert just because
of the font right it's going to convert
for a plethora of other reasons so the
the efficacy the thing that you're
trying to measure is impacted not just
by the treatment but a huge number of
covariance okay and in the examples I
was telling you about you know earlier
you know it's not unusual to find that
you know once you kind of categorize
those covariance you're looking at you
know a thousand or even five thousand
dimensional vector right so you're
looking at a large number you know
you're looking at a large number of
covariance and so when this happens the
natural sort of thing that comes up is
statistical efficiency right if I just
kind of
randomly sampled and allocated to two
groups that's that's that's unlikely to
be that's unlikely to be sufficient and
I'll give you a you know a stronger
sense of that as we as we go along so
okay so if we're gonna do if we're gonna
sort of go for efficiency right
intuitively what do you want to do so
intuitively you want to do something
that's referred to as stratification and
what stratification is is nothing but at
the end of the day you know after you're
done with your allocation to plus one
and minus one and you look at the
distribution of covariates in either of
those groups you want those
distributions to look really really
similar okay now if you have two
covariants it's pretty easy to see that
you know this is a very straightforward
approach and indeed this kind of a
textbook approach of doing things right
but as soon as you have a slightly
larger number of kaveri it's even let's
say you get the five right doing
something like stratification doesn't
necessarily make sense anymore so what
does one do well turns out there's a
huge literature associated with this
right and you know we kind of stumbled
along discovering this literature over
the last over the last few years you
know it's fair to say it's the
literature is actually gigantic and so
what I'm showing you over here it's kind
of a little bit of sort of my bias plus
the literature right so you're getting
to see the literature through my biased
eyes but nonetheless right I would
actually track all of this back to
experiment design right so in the last
half ounce sort of referred to to Fisher
in the 30s and really I think a lot of
this stuff you know goes all the way
back to sort of this seminal textbook
that he wrote in the mid 30s
more sort of modern treatments of that
topic or it's so broad this book by very
nice book actually by book of shine on
experiment design more generally and
then for a betta so what I'm thinking of
as a/b test there's this sort of very
comprehensive sort of book by Baldy
Agostini right so what are the problems
though that you know one one kind of
formulates over here so you served two
classes of problems right and we're sort
of talking about optimization now right
so sort of the offline problem and if
you focus on the offline problem for a
bit the idea what the offline problem is
you collect all of your you
subjects before you make an assignment
okay so you register all of your
subjects and don't make an assignment to
them so you register all of them first
right and having then registered them
you want to split them into into sort of
these two groups to kind of best balance
you know the distribution of covariates
in those two groups so yeah this is also
fairly old this is sort of a nice kind
of paper for you know applications of
this sort of stuff it's more in the
social sciences than anything else and
more recently you know folks have
actually been been positing and
proposing combinatorial optimization
problems to solve exactly this sort of
problem so Jose zubizarreta
is a statistician at Columbia and he's
written sort of a series of papers where
he proposes a bunch of these mixed
integer programs to actually solve this
it's actually gotten a huge amount of
excitement and buzz going in you know in
in this world right it's not the offline
problem well I'm more interested in is
today although I'll say something about
the offline problem is the online
problem right so the online problem is
one where you don't get the chance to
collect all of you know your subjects a
priori before you can get sign it rather
a subject walks in and given all the
information you have thus far which is
the existing allocation plus bar you
decide whether you want to put that
subject in plus one or minus one okay so
turns out that again there's sort of a
fairly rich literature associated with
this problem starting all the way back
with sort of Brad Efrain in the early
70s so Brad proposed this thing called a
biased coin design right in the early
70s if you just googled biased coin
design you would probably get a thousand
papers now that have flowed from this
sort of one seminal paper in the early
70s and his paper was kind of motivated
by a very very simple simple sort of
need write his paper was motivated by
the need of preserving balance at any
point in the experiment between the
number of people assigned to plus 1 or
minus 1 right so yeah you know if you if
you if you assign plus 1 minus 1
uniformly at random you get the sort of
square root n type difference between
the two groups his idea was actually you
know maybe what we can do is effectively
using something like an urn strategy
make sure
we kind of preserve balance between the
two groups as we go along but at the
same time have randomness in the process
so it's hard to manipulate now what
ended up happening is that idea of
Ephron has led to a vast literature
where as opposed to just balancing the
number of subjects in the two groups
people have tried to come up with
heuristics algorithms to effectively
balance not just the count but also a
variety of statistics typically first
and second order statistics of the
various covariance in the two groups
okay and all these papers that I'm
talking about over here are kind of
fundamental in that regard now one of
the interesting things about really all
of this work over here as you pick up
any of these papers they follow the
following kind of trajectory right so
paper will set up the problem not unlike
how I've set it up just now they'll
present an algorithm the algorithm will
typically be some sort of index rule
okay so they'll present that index rule
and then they'll present a bunch of
analysis as to why that index rule is
good and you know there's this paper by
Atkinson in 2015 that I was looking at
last night as I was putting together a
lit review he actually does this
compendium of all the all the
industrials that exist right and there's
I counted like 30 in his paper right so
there's a huge number of these index
rules all kind of analyzed after the
fact and in some some sense it kind of
leaves this uncomfortable feeling of
what what are we actually trying to do
what's the actual problem here how do we
actually come up with something that
makes you know progress in a very sort
of principled kind of way and that's
that's really that's really one of the
things I'm you know that I'm going to
try try and accomplish okay so that's
that's kind of background I'm not gonna
get into the talk proper okay and the
plan for the rest of the talk is a to
kind of set up a model all right so I'm
going to set up a model you'll have to
take my word for it that the model is in
some ways very very standard to to this
sort of literature over here having set
up the model I'm going to then propose
two problems an offline problem and an
online problem and we'll discuss them in
turn okay so that's that's kind of
that's kind of the idea and then as I
was saying if time permits at the end
I'll show you
some results with sort of real-world
clickstream data and I'll talk about a
few open problems okay so as I said the
first thing we're gonna have to do is
assume some sort of functional form for
Y okay if you don't have a functional
form it's very hard to make progress and
in fact certain ice annals of stats
paper from a few years ago that kind of
formalizes that so what's the sort of
the canonical functional form that
actually gets used right so this is the
effectively the canonical functional
form with covariance right that's
trivial it's a linear form and what it's
saying is the following
write little K over here indexes
subjects right so subjects are indexed
by little kick right y sub K is you know
the treatment effect that you would
observe for the kid subject right and
that's a function of how you treated
that subject right so it's a function of
XK so was it plus 1 or minus 1 and it's
also a function of all of the covariance
that that subject actually comes with
okay so it's a function of this ZK as
well and you know for what I'm gonna do
next you know ZK is gonna be a
p-dimensional vector and this noise over
here this epsilon over here I'm gonna
assume is independent of everything else
it's exotic ok yes okay is indexing
subjects or patients or impressions or
whatever you want to call it right so to
remember so remember we said where a
patient comes in think of a the
canonical example of a patient comes in
you assign the patient of treatment I'm
indexing those patients by kick unknown
doctor right that so so this is okay
it's a very good great so what do we
know in this model so other than the
fact that it's linear we don't have to
ok so we don't know what kappa and we
don't know what theta is okay so theta
is a scalar cap as a p-dimensional
vector we don't know either
okay now if I write things down this way
what what's the average treatment effect
right well in this particular case right
the average treatment of fact are simply
2 theta so really my goal at the end of
the day is actually to estimate what
theta is
right so let's do the following right
let's say that what we did right now
I'll justify this in a second but let's
say we did this okay let's say that what
we did is we came up with some
allocation right so we have we have we
have all of these these impressions or
treatments or whatever it is coming in
we have a total of little n of them
right we allocate each of them to either
plus 1 or minus 1 ok we get to observe
all the outcomes which is why right and
then what we do is let's say we decide
to learn theta by doing least squares
look at because for each guy I've got
the kobarid factor I know whether it was
plus 1 or minus 1 I observe what ended
up happening
I do least squares and from least
squares among other things I can pick
out theta right if I did that right the
variance of our estimate of theta is
then simply write Sigma square which is
kind of this noise you can't get away
from right it's the the variance of the
exogenous noise divided by this
quadratic form in X I'm not going to
interpret the quadratic form yet because
it's got a nice interpretation that'll
come by later right for now let's just
think about it as it's got there's some
quadratic form in X and this matrix P
over here is a function of the covariant
vector x' for each of the observed each
of the observed observed subjects so far
okay everybody would think yeah ok so
let's say we had this right and of
course there's a lot left on the table
right why are we doing least squares etc
etc we'll get to that in a second right
but let's say we have this right one of
the things you might want to do is
minimize the variance right off your
estimate of theta or equivalently
maximize efficiency which is efficiency
is the the reciprocal of this quantity
right so this you know this leads to
immediately sort of an offline problem
right so the first offline problem weeks
or the offline problem we can propose
right is what I want to do is come up
with an allocation of these subjects to
plus one minus one that maximizes the
efficiency of my estimate of theta ok so
that's one thing I can do and that's the
offline problem it's offline because
solidus requires I be able to see Z
let's I'll need to actually observe all
of the covariance of everybody coming in
before I can solve this
the online problem which is a little bit
scarier is the following right so at the
end of the day I care about the same
metric right I care about the efficiency
of my asta mate but now I can only talk
about the expected efficiency and this
expectation is over the process see
right the expectation is over the
process of covariance that actually
arrived over time Z right so what am I
actually saying over here right so what
I'm saying over here is that as I
actually assign to the kit guy right the
only information I can use is the
allocations that I've made thus far and
the Z vectors that I've observed thus
far okay interestingly you'll also
notice that I'm not allowing myself to
observe wise read this is something that
actually came up in the last talk right
do we actually observe the outcome or
not we don't observe the outcome over
here read you just observed what you
allocate it and what the covariance you
know what the covary what these
corporate vectors were up to that point
in time
okay so I'll find an online problems
mix-ups yeah so the offline I can see
the maximizing the quadratic form is
like minimizing one over the quadratic
form would go into city that's not no
that's not right so in some ways the
expectation of one although yeah yeah so
so very good right so I guess we're to
start somewhere
correct and in some ways the idea was
come up with an optimization problem
where two things happen one we can kind
of make progress and talk about what's
optimal right and to kind of put all of
the other stuff that exists in the
context of the problem so it turns out
when I actually look at efficiency I get
both of those things when I look at the
expected value of one over the thing I
don't so it's sort of a you know it's
it's a formulation choice that we've had
that we made over here but it's not like
one is any more fundamental than the
other presumably down one in terms of
the other yeah you could but it's too
loose too
yeah so at the end of the day you're
actually dealing with quantities that
are on the same order as what you would
get if you try to actually bound one
over the other right because you need
some low variance kind of stuff
happening good good good
so in fact hold that question for the
next slide right so really let's let's
actually just step back for a quick
second right so what is the chroma or
album tell us so the criminal bound
would tell us right that provided X and
Z were exaltedness that is to say that x
and z are independent of the absalon's
right then really you know the best
estimator that I have for Thea for this
this data this this treatment effect
that I'm trying to learn is in fact
least squares right and the expression
that I was trying to sort of minimize in
some sense he's in fact the variance of
that best estimator if I stuck with this
assumption of throwing away the observed
Y's right I can now at least start to
talk about what an optimal estimator is
and what an optimal allocation is in
light of that estimator now this
actually leaves leaves open a bunch of
interesting questions right so if you
actually allow yourself to observe wise
it's really unclear how to even pose the
question of thinking about the optimal
estimator so if I so indeed I think
that's that's an interesting question
right if you observed wise you could
present presumably think about doing all
sorts of sort of biased estimation
techniques very difficult to actually
think about even sort of starting out
with saying what is the optimal
estimator and that's adding okay so
that's what we're so that's what we're
doing over here we're not getting to
look at at what the Y's are okay so
because of that right because all I get
to look at is the X's thus far the
allocations I've seen thus far and the
covariant vector starts part I can
actually say that well actually what
these problems are doing is maximizing
efficiency for the best unbiased
estimate okay
this in practice I mean if you did use
the Y and you did something with the by
so so I have literally like one data
point on that and I'm afraid to kind of
talk so okay so one data point I know
off where you can actually do this we
have seen impact is actually using a be
testing in execution of financial trades
against sort of dark pools and things of
that nature right and over there you
definitely want to observe the why right
that's you know what what ended up
happening it's not clear to me whether
this formulation is actually the
appropriate formulation over there I
would almost want to say that some kind
of bandit problem is the appropriate
formulation over there because over
there you care about two things right
you care about learning the treatment of
fact theta but you also don't want to
make losses as you're kind of learning
data right over here I really just care
about learning theta at the end of the
day makes sense right all right so we've
posed two problems and I want to solve
these problems okay and have the rest of
the talk so first off the offline tom is
actually easy right and that's because
peasy perp is a projection matrix so
it's positive semi-definite so at the
end of the day you know we've got this
nice government's williamson type you
know approximation algorithm for it you
can come up with a D randomization of it
if you're worried about the noise and
you introduced by the randomization and
I don't care about constants because you
know it's I'm talking about
statistically optimal over here so doing
the offline problem is actually easy and
in fact the one thing that that I find
actually interesting over here is it's
easy only in this kind of very specific
setting right so other sort of ad hoc
measures of covariant imbalance right so
I'd alluded to some of these mixed
integer programming papers that I was
talking about earlier you can't get to
sort of at least as far as I can tell
you can't necessarily get to an
efficient approximation algorithm in
those settings so there's a sort of nice
thing that happens over here that when
we talk about this particular
formulation we get an offline problem
that's actually easy so don't really
care nearly as much about the offline
problem but one of the things you can do
in this setting please ask the question
of well those optimization actually
matter right so what difference does
optimization make and in the
setting it's kind of easier to think
about the impact of optimization so they
take a digression for a couple of
minutes and and actually talk about but
what does you know what does
optimization do for you over here right
so the top of the value of optimization
right V so V let's say randomization
right let's actually construct the
generative family okay
so leg a very simple generative family
of covariance right the first component
of the covariant of this cover back
there has to be one if it's not one you
can't necessarily think about this as a
be testing otherwise you could assign
everything to a and still learn the
impact on beep okay so the first one is
always been happy one and that's just
sort of a convention the rest they just
that's just a normal random vector okay
so assume that these kobarid back to our
sort of normal random vectors and really
I'm kind of as I sat right interested in
the setting where P is actually really
large so in fact what I'm gonna do is
make P in fact that largest can be which
is n minus one right in in this setting
for everything to kind of make sense in
the context of what I talked about and
say well what's the difference between
optimization and randomization okay so
here's a simple calculation right so if
you randomized right I just randomly
assign it to plus 1 or minus 1 and I
asked myself well what's the efficiency
right off of what I just estimated right
it looks like this and in particular
what that saying is that right if P were
n minus 1 right so consider this
ensemble of instances right where you
you you grow the sort of the dimension
of the covariant vector as you grow the
number of samples right if P were n
minus 1 this is an extreme where you
actually wouldn't learn right you want
the efficiency to grow like N and it's
not gonna grow like n right now what
happens if you randomized in the same
Sun okay so as I was saying ideally we
want this quantity grow with them right
so the question is can optimization in
this very extreme setting allow for
learning and the surprising answer is
actually yes right that is taking that
same that same example that I just
talked about we can actually
characterize the optimal value of this
of this optimization problem over here
right and in fact show that this
efficiency is going to sort of scale
like an OK
which is sort of the best possible
skilling that that you can hope for
right so for large P HP is n minus 1
says as large can be you know the
efficiency under randomization is order
1 but as you don't learn and with
optimization its Omega okay so so this
is kind of a very sharp sort of example
in reality you'd imagine that it's going
to be weaker but it kind of you know
brings out this difference between
optimization and pure randomization yeah
yeah so for this to make sense right I'm
actually it's for this to make sense I'm
considering an ensemble of problems in
that ensemble as n grows P is allowed to
grow with n right
the people are fixed really all bets are
off right exactly so in fact over here
as long as P n is smaller than n minus 1
you're gonna get growth with n and n
minus 1 as we saw with that
randomization you wouldn't get growth
with an you get a constant
okay so let me actually skip this okay
actually talked about the online problem
right and this way I want to spend some
time so we just spoke at the offline
problem the online problem it's
effectively the same thing right except
that as I said we've actually got to
make these allocation decisions on the
fly
step by step right so first guy comes in
I've got to make an allocation decision
for the second I I get to look at the
allocation I made for the first guy his
covariant vector and the covariance for
the second guy okay so that's the
problem I want to solve it's very hard
to make progress on any meaningful
progress on this problem without
assuming you know distribution so to
speak for Z so for what I'm going to
talk about next I'm going to assume
right that disease each of these Z's are
independent vectors from an elliptical
distribution okay so basically all I
need is spherical symmetry so just think
of it as multivariate normal if you like
right but it doesn't have to be
multivariate normal
right you could have you know bimodal
sort of magnitudes for these batteries
okay but assume that the independent
vectors from an elliptical distribution
and the punchline of this whole thing is
I'm going to provide a simple
computationally efficient and
approximately optimal algorithm for this
problem
okay so right at the get-go right oops
sorry
surrender the get-go right this is this
is pretty nasty-looking right so if you
actually look at X if you look at this
quadratic form over here it doesn't
separate over time in a clean in a clean
way so the first step that we're gonna
try and make right
it's the somehow simplify this objective
so let's actually stare at this
objective for a quick sock I can't
understand what this objective is
telling us to do right so really this is
just me writing out what X transpose px
is right and what I want to do is
interpret some of these quantities okay
so what is this
right so gamma and inverse over here
right what is that you can think of that
as being an empirical
sujin matrix okay so gamma and inverse
is an empirical precision matrix that's
all it is
okay the empirical precision matrix that
you get from looking at the and observed
covariance so far and what is this
quantity
you know what is this summation over
here the summation is a very natural
quantity right remember that the X is 1
plus 1 or minus 1 right so what this is
doing is this is adding up all of the D
and covariant vectors according to
whether you set them to plus 1 or minus
1 right now if you think about it
intuitively we wanted balance right so
if we want balance we want these
covariant vectors effectively to kind of
balance out we'd want this sum over here
to be small in some sense right and what
this what this for a functional form is
doing is it's encouraging exactly that
ok so it's saying that basically right
we'd like this quadratic form
effectively in this covariant imbalance
over here and we want to minimize that
ok so that's what's actually that's
what's actually going on so the first
step I'm gonna make and it's gonna be
heuristic for now and I'll formalize it
on the next slide I'll prove a theorem
on the next slide right let's say we
passed it up to the following limit
right which is basically look at the
empirical precision matrix over here
right I just replace it by its limit
okay now this is this is problematic
right because really I want to consider
settings where P actually grows with n
right and I'm just sort of thinking of
things in terms of the law of large
numbers of you we can't do that the
second issue is right in replacing you
know this quantity by some other
quantity we'll have to actually worry
about how smooth the control is right
that the the optimal solution is with
respect to this objective so it's a bit
delicate but we'll get the back when we
do okay
so first up take this this empirical
precision matrix and replace it by its
limit without you doing allocations only
counting the number of assignments
well you know actually um so that's what
I'm using all of them well he's coming
you using
okay so allocation rule you are using
this really done let's come back right
okay so basically right hey are you good
for me using it as a ZK something so not
talked about the optimal problem yet
right so the optimum problem is
presumably this very nasty control
problem that depends on the entire
sequence thus far right and you'll see
in a quick second that after I make this
this approximation I'll actually reduce
this to a DP but it's still a high
dimensional DP okay so I see where
you're going with this right I see where
you're going with this but the point is
that in generality you need the sequence
sufficient statistic is not obvious so
to speak
okay so if I need this substitution
right I'm gonna rewrite this and it's
like a more compact notation right I'm
actually gonna look at this objective
it's replaced by right two quantities
over here right one is this quantity
little Delta N squared right that's
actually counting the imbalance in the
number of number of assignments to
either group right and a second is this
is what what Balaji is thinking of right
I look at this quantity capital Delta n
that's I'm summing up the covariant
factor right lady imbalanced Kaveri
factor the spot and I'm hoping for that
to actually be small at the end of the
day okay so what I'm saying is I'm
trying to i want to approximate this
with this oh that raises two questions
so first of all why would I want their
approximated short answer to that is it
actually lets me fall back on some
dynamic programming methodology I'm
still not home free but at least let me
start thinking about that the second
thing is I can show that actually
solving this problem is in fact very
similar to solving this problem so in
particular this is sort of the you know
the the surrogacy that that we're
proposing and what we can say is
effectively right that if we solve this
surrogate problem came up with an
optimal solution to the surrogate
problem okay
it's an epsilon approximation to the
original problem that we actually
started out okay important note here is
that we've got it as I said let P grow
with n and in fact we do like P grow
with n for this for this result to hold
okay so really all I've done so far one
second dog so all I've done so far is I
start out with that that online problem
I said it looks really a little messy
and so I've made a simplification and
I've come up with this alternative
problem over here and all I'm saying is
that when I saw this alternative problem
the solution I get is actually close to
the original problem Bob and then I'll
come back to comment no my problem I had
been assuming that the matrix Sigma was
unknown to the
your maker and so I'm confused as to why
it's without muscle generality to assume
that it's there yeah yeah good so good
good so I'm gonna have to assume I know
Sigma for all the examples that I was
actually talking about
that's actually really reasonable right
because this is a function of the
population that I'm actually sampling
from so think of it as like you know
okay I want to actually figure out the
efficacy of a particular ad on Facebook
I'm trying to learn the efficacy of the
ad the covariant distribution is well
known I have thousands and thousands and
no millions and millions of samples of
that so I'm gonna actually assume that
Sigma is in fact no coming that the
samples are coming iid from this
distribution of z KS right yes
absolutely absolutely yeah absolutely
yes Sigma if they mention P is it it is
yep I see it's P minus 1 right because
I'm taking out that the one for the
constants so I've come up with I went
from one hard problem through a
different hard problem which is this one
all right so first off right let's
observe that at least I can sort of
write down a dynamic program for this
problem right in particular it's a
dynamic program that admits right a
fixed dimensional state space
representation right so the state ID
need to actually track over here is
little Delta K that's a number right
that's the imbalance between the two
groups and then capital Delta K which is
the imbalance in balance in the
covariance between the two groups okay
this is still not easy because we're
left with a high dimensional dynamic
optimization problem let's fix the
maximum but high right so it's a
p-dimensional dynamic optimization
problem
and just just to kind of complete that
loop over there right it's good this is
correct because really all I care about
to actually compute this is I just need
to know a little Delta and capital doubt
I don't need I don't need the sequence
so that was actually the whole point of
actually taking out that empirical
precision matrix and putting the real
thing actually in there I would really I
wouldn't necessarily be able to play
this game if I didn't do that now the
next step is actually a state space
collapse okay which is that what I want
to do is go from ap dimensional dynamic
optimization problem to a low
dimensional dynamic optimization problem
that's what I'm going to do next okay so
as we've kind of summarized thus far we
got to a DP that state space whose state
space was little Delta and capital Delta
right that's in P dimensions it turns
out that I can actually solve it
suffices to solve a DP in two dimensions
okay
namely it's the prices to track little
Delta and just this weird norm it's
called the Mahalanobis distance of
capital Delta okay what's behind this so
what's behind this is actually something
fairly simple and serendipitous okay
so effectively it just relies on this
and you'll see why this this very simple
calculation will actually make a
difference in a sake okay so yeah yes
right if I look at the inner product of
any multivariate Gaussian random
variable right with an arbitrary capital
Delta right in this weird kind of inner
product where it's important that the
Sigma over here match the covariance
matrix of the Z right then in order to
know the distribution of this I don't
need to know capital Delta okay I can
write down the distribution of this
quantity without knowing capital Delta
all I need to know is this Marlin Obus
norm of capital Delta okay so that's
that's a simple key observation right it
works only if it's in this inner product
right and you'll see how this kind of
serendipitous Lee helps lives in a
socket is there
yeah absolutely this is this is exactly
where that comes okay so so how are we
using that right so using it as follows
right in fact let's kind of plays movie
forward right let's look at sort of the
induction argument over here right so at
the penultimate time step at time n
right you're at some state little Delta
n minus 1 capital Delta n minus 1 okay
and I've kind of written it down and
it's gory detail over there right now
really a time n plus 1 which is the
terminal state right
what's your state going to be right well
you're gonna take that and it's ample
that arrives and you're either gonna
assign it to plus 1 or minus 1 right
which takes little Delta to little Delta
n minus 1 plus cap X n right that's
gonna take capital Delta to capital
Delta n minus 1 plus the covariant
vector with the appropriate sign right
was it plus 1 or minus 1 right mixup
right okay now this was the last time
step right and we incur our only kind of
terminal cost in this last time step so
the terminal cost was this quantity over
here all right this should be a squared
norm I'm missing it but square over
there right so so that's not a problem
now let's actually think about this
right if I expand this out what's it
going to depend on it's gonna depend on
this Moldova's norm of Delta right it's
going to depend on effectively you know
the covariance matrix for Z right and
it's going to depend on that seam in a
product that I showed you in the last
slide okay and if you remember that you
know product actually depended on Delta
only through its Marlon Obus norm so in
particular right using the insight from
the previous slide right in distribution
this quantity right I can write down
this quantity knowing just the malla
nobis norm of capital Delta n minus 1
okay so what was sort of serendipitous
about this was a couple different steps
right one it feels really hard to kind
of pull this off without actually
replacing the empirical precision matrix
with its precision matrix ok to this
goes back to sort of an early question
that was asked by the actual formulation
at the you know at the end of the day
should you go with maximizing
efficiency one of our variants why even
look at efficiency of variants right it
seems like you know this particular kiss
this sort of works out really really
cleanly and you know that's kind of the
serendipity of sort of what's happening
over here okay so as I say at the end of
the day you got a two dimensional
optimization problem now what I really
like about this is the following so if
you go back to that original literature
right that I point to do at the very
start people think about all sorts of
generalizations off the a B testing
problem that we started out with
so I mean aim to write that are actually
pretty important so one is having a
budget right so it's talking about 50/50
over here right if you talk about having
a budget you say well actually right I
can only assign three percent of my
impressions or three percent of whatever
to to this test right the the space of
heuristics is actually pretty new
there's literally four or five papers on
this topic that actually extend the
existing heuristics so it's some sort of
hack right if you want to budget over
here it actually flows from the same
kind of dynamic programming argument
okay another version of the problem is
and this is actually important in
settings where you care about
manipulation maximizing not just
efficiency but also caring about how
unpredictable your assignment actually
was okay so turns out there's actually a
way people actually think about this in
hindsight like how unpredictable was you
know was was the trial that you actually
ran and again solving that problem ends
up becoming a low dimensional dynamic
program okay so really this sort of
simple dynamic programming methodology
lends itself to lots of variants of the
problem let me actually skip this this
is actually this actually just results
on this yahoo clickstream data set I
mean all it's really showing is
effectively that if you optimized over
sort of just a randomized trial there's
a lot of power
excuse me to the optimization what am I
going to talk about just in Part II is
sort of some of these open you know some
of the open problems that this actually
leaves right so I think first off one is
proving correctness for generalizations
so once you actually write down this
dynamic program like I did it's actually
pretty easy to start writing down then
programs for all sorts of variants of
this you know this of this optinal a/b
testing problem the issue is the the
theorem that I showed you where we
replace that empirical precision matrix
with the exact precision matrix that
theorem is a lot of work and every one
of these generalizations actually
requires revisiting that theorem to
actually think about whether it works or
doesn't work sorry I kind of think about
this I sort of low hanging fruit though
another one and I think this is much
more important is thinking about models
where you know a priori that your
dependence on covariance is sparse okay
so I wrote down that linear model right
and I said nothing about Kappa Alpha
could be anything but what if for
instance you knew that you know actually
the real Kappa is in fact sparse so I
think that's actually a very a very very
realistic problem right and a lot of
these settings and what that requires is
effectively thinking about the original
least squares problem I talked about and
as opposed to viewing it as a least
squares problem you'd need to think
about a regular eyes version of that
problem
now the regularization was Ridge
regression so you have a two norm I
believe that a lot of the results I
talked about actually go through pretty
simply but if it's the LA Zoo which I
think is more important for sparsity
then it's really unclear what to do
so third thing you know I made this
assumption of you know elliptical
distributions one interesting question
is whether we can sort of employ some
sort of CLT to say that well you know in
in reality we don't we don't really need
that we don't really need that that that
that requirement and then finally you
know I'm looking at everything in sort
of dynamic in this sort of dynamic
programs programming setting I don't
really don't know what sort of the
appropriate sort of adversarial results
would be for the same online problem
that I talked about if you wanted to
think about those covariant vectors as
being you know from some general
adversarial family so that's all I had
think I'm good on time too
so that's another big set of open
problems so so so basically right one
thing you could do is see if you say you
think a hypothesis faster right have to
do so after you do something like what I
just talked about the natural kind of
hypothesis have to do some kind of
presentation which you could easily do
but I think the real sort of thing and
this leads to a different form of
formulation altogether is insisting that
when you make allegations you make
allegations in pairs okay so that is to
say right at the end of the day after
you've observed an even number of vibes
right
they've all been actually put together
in case that they've actually been put
together in pairs now at the very end of
the day you can actually randomize by
flipping a coin right and that sort of
half of the fact they mix hypothesis
testing much easier but the optimization
problems that I talked about in here
also seem to get
so it makes me have biological Parker
from Stanford University is going to
talk about stable marriages and metric
spaces